my name's tom for the last four years
i've been running the part of mi5
which looks at the threat from the
russian state my name is kate
i've been in the service for about the
last 14 years
doing a variety of roles largely in
investigations i'm currently working
on the russia mission
tom and kate met me at mi5's
little-known
underground museum at their thames house
headquarters in london
to talk about countering the threat from
russia
in the gray zone it's the first time
anyone involved in such top-secret
counter-intelligence work for the
security service
has agreed to an interview they were
using actors to voice
their words to protect their identities
tom came to the meeting with a small
black box in one hand
he placed it on a table as we said hello
and then suggested i open it
inside was a smaller pale pink
oblong box with the words premiere
nina richie eau de parfum
printed on it in dark purple letters
it's about the size of a small pack of
cards about half as thick
maybe about the length of my finger i
flipped it open
to reveal a tiny perfume bottle half
filled
with a yellowy coloured liquid all
innocent looking enough but this is a
mock-up
of the actual perfume bottle and box
used by two suspected russian hitmen
when they tried to kill former spy
sergey skripal
and his daughter yulia with the nerve
agent novichok
in march 2018 in the english city of
salisbury
it is a really powerful demonstration of
just how easy it was to
just to slip this into the uk and how
reckless the attack in salisbury was
given it presumably came in in
somebody's pocket or some luggage on the
flight
i asked tom if mi5 could stop another
salisbury style attack
he says the agency is doing everything
it can
but there are no absolute guarantees
in the gray zone
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor
at sky news and you're listening to my
podcast
into the gray zone which explores a
murky evolution of warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this final episode we hear from two
mi5 officers
about operating in the gray zone and how
their work
is having to change to keep up with the
threat
this includes doing more with what they
know like agreeing to this
interview something that was sanctioned
by ken mccallum
the director general of the security
[Music]
service
[Music]
the russia threat to the uk has been a
feature of the national security
landscape for the uk
for almost the entire history of mi5
certainly for decades
the nature of the threat i think is
possibly changing
given the increased use of for example
cyber
social media the 24-hour news cycle the
pace at which things move in the media
and internationally
i think has speeded up it means the
nature of the job
of a counter-intelligence officer like
tom is also having to change
counter-intelligence or
counter-espionage
is what spy agencies call the act of
disrupting attempts by foreign states
to steal secrets insert agents
even carry out assassinations it pitches
spy
against spy in what had traditionally
been a relatively slow-moving game
of deception patience and counter-attack
but new operations in the gray zone are
changing the old rules
when tom talks about ct he's referring
to counter terrorism
another key area of work for mi5 there's
a sort of sense
maybe that historically the work the
counter intelligence work
was a sort of game of chess move and
counter move
but maybe at a slightly lower pace than
maybe some of the other aspects of
certainly national security work around
ct
i would say that that is that is kind of
a historic narrative now i would say
what we are now seeing is the evolution
of a threat
which is as near as it's ever going to
be kind of
a real-time threat which requires
real-time responses
both from the agencies the intelligence
community and
from policymakers so i think you'll just
see an acceleration of the constant
competition as you describe it
the phrase constant competition is one
military chiefs used to try and
capture this idea of countries attacking
each other in the gray zone
just below the threshold of war
as we've heard throughout this series it
means anything can be used as a weapon
from cyber attacks and disinformation to
business deals and politics
it makes for a broad unpredictable and
evolving range of threats for mi5 to
deal with
so i i'm really curious about how you
deal with that
as an intelligence agency because you've
got the professional intelligence
officers which is like your your bread
and butter
dealing with that but then you also have
this murky gray zone world
where journalists can potentially be
exploited where information can be used
where elections can be meddled with
where businesses can be corrupted or
coerced into acting a certain way
how can you possibly deal with all of
that i think you've hit the nail on the
head really
the complexity of that so on the one
hand
we have a sense of what you might
describe as the traditional threat
which is the intelligence services which
operate in ways which are
broadly understood in a very kind of
disciplined if ruthless way
and then you have the evolution of this
threat into another area the gray zone
as you'd describe it
where this is going to be very very
difficult for us
the question we find ourselves asking
around the kind of work you're
describing is
to what degree is this state driven to
what degree is it for political or state
outcomes
to what degree are the people involved
in it aware that they are involved in it
there's a question for us given our kind
of resource constraints about
to what degree does it matter and we're
very keen to avoid getting into a kind
of debate about
you know policing the internet or going
anywhere near
which looks like interfering with free
speech so you also then
get into a question about how do you
avoid
as an intelligence community talking
about whether
you know message x or message y was
successful
in what it was setting out to do so what
we are spending our time thinking more
about is
what was the intention behind it it
means
mi5 and the uk's other intelligence
agencies
are having to adapt how they work to
fight
an increasingly diverse challenge that
stretches
from dark alleyways to cyberspace
kate investigates russia's military
intelligence agency
the gru including a unit
suspected of carrying out the solsby spy
poisonings
that we covered in episode one i asked
her
how she views the gray zone it's a tough
one
it isn't a term i use on a daily basis
but
certainly this podcast has made me think
about the fact that actually a lot of
what we do
is is looking in that space
i think that makes responding harder
there isn't a set of responses for how
you deal with stuff going on
in the gray zone particularly when you
start to think about things like
political influence
some of the activity going on in
cyberspace
we don't yet have all the kind of laws
that would give you a sort of black and
white answer
for responding to that type of activity
that can make it challenging when you're
looking at it because when you're
investigating anything
you want to think that there's an end
state where something is no longer
a threat you know you've managed that
threat in some way
whether that's arresting someone that
can no longer pose a threat or having
sanctions or whatever
there is a range of things that we can
do but some of this stuff when we're
dealing with hostile states and dealing
with activity in the gray zone there
aren't
always an easy set of response options
and that just makes it all the more
challenging when you're investigating it
tom said work by the uk's intelligence
community
to adapt to the grayzone threat was
underway
before the poisoning of former russian
spy
sergey skripal and his daughter yulia in
salisbury
but the shock of the first chemical
weapons attack
on european soil since the second world
war accelerated this change
my name's tom i have been in mi5 for
really quite a long time probably longer
than i care to remember
i've worked in a whole series of
different parts of the organization both
on investigations
and operations largely on
counter-terrorism including northern
ireland and
islamist counter-terrorism i've done a
range of
corporate functions and for the last
four years i've been running the part of
mi5
which looks at the threat from the
russian state tom described
the moment he learned of the attack on
sergey and yulia skripal
it came as a complete shock to everybody
in my team
i remember we were we were on a
management away day believe it or not
when we received a message that two
people had been found on a park bench in
salisbury
russian nationals and that they appeared
to be exhibiting symptoms of poisoning
by the time we were back in thames house
it became apparent who these individuals
were
and at that point mi5 and partners swung
into action
we have an intelligence operations
center here so that was opened and
huge resources were starting to flow in
very quickly to try to understand what
had happened
and what the threat might be
investigators discovered the father and
daughter had been poisoned with a liquid
nerve agent called novichok
disguised in a perfume bottle and
sprayed on their front door
by two suspected gru hitmen on the 4th
of march 2018.
um the next six months was a kind of
like living through a bit of a
being in the eye of a hurricane a very
large
media story internationally unfolding
around us with
political international relations
intelligence police angles to it
and through that our core focus was
understanding what had happened
and bringing those to account once the
perfume dispenser
used in the attack was recovered
scientists at the uk's defense
laboratory at porton down
mocked up a replica which could be shown
to ministers
foreign allies and as luck would have it
me it's about the size of a small pack
of cards
about half as thick maybe about the
length of my finger
it's a sort of pink metallic box and
when you open the box there is a much
smaller bottle
about three inches long with a small
amount of yellowy liquid in it and a
long
nozzle applicator in it which was
presumably there to protect the
assailants when they were deploying the
novichok
it is a really powerful demonstration of
just how easy it was to
just to slip this into the uk and how
reckless the attack in salisbury was
given it presumably came in in
somebody's pocket or some luggage on the
flight
tom said mi5 can't possibly guarantee to
be able to stop
every future grayson style assassination
attempt
but it can and is adapting the way it
works
to stand a better chance i think we have
entered
the same realm that we are in with our
counter-terrorism colleagues which is
that we do absolutely everything we can
to stop any events from taking place in
the uk which
are damaging the uk population or
property
but there are no absolute guarantees we
are doing absolutely everything we can
every day right across government to
make this the hardest possible operating
environment for our adversaries
we are making it as difficult as we can
for them to get in and we are then
investigating and taking action where we
see hostile state activity
wherever it is in the uk my name is kate
i work in mi5 the security service i've
been in the service for
about the last 14 years doing a variety
of roles
largely in investigations i'm currently
working
on the russia mission so countering the
threat
from russia kate who i interviewed
separately
told me about her work investigating the
team
accused of the salisbury spy poisonings
a gru
unit known as 29155
it's also been linked to other
grayzone-style attacks
including a failed coup plot against the
government of montenegro
the poisoning of a bulgarian arms dealer
and the alleged payment of bounties to
the taliban
for killing nato troops in afghanistan
russia has previously denied such
allegations
the first thing i'd say is that all of
those operations that you've highlighted
there represent the breadth of the units
kind of
malign activities both the spread of
those activities globally but also the
scope
so sabotage subversion
through to assassination and i would say
kind of both as horrific acts in their
own right but also combined they
demonstrate the extreme nature of the
activity conducted by this unit
and they are all activities outside of
what we would consider
appropriate for a government agency to
be involved in
i mean you've been looking into this
unit as part of your work
can you sort of talk a bit more about
what you've learned
like what's the most surprising or
interesting thing about the kind of
activities that they do
and are willing to do in all honesty
the thing i find most interesting is not
so much the activity they're doing
but the international response that it's
prompted
lots of which has already been captured
in the world's press
and in some arenas has kind of generated
significant interest which has led to
ongoing exposure of the units activities
and is very much keeping it in the media
she didn't offer any specifics but one
example
is the work of the investigative website
bellingcat
which we talked about in the first
episode
its investigators have used information
from internet searches
trawling databases and analyzing images
to reveal
details about the alleged skripal
attackers
and others the presentation of
evidence-based facts
is one of the best ways to uncover the
truth behind a gray zone attack
which will typically be layered in
ambiguity
and denied by the perpetrator there's
clearly a
shared sense of shock amongst
international
partners that another state would want
to interfere
you know in the most kind of horrific
way
be that a willingness to conduct murder
on the streets of europe or
to subvert and sabotage a democratic
process
and i think it's the diversity
of the unit's victims so
from people that they might consider
traitors to russia
through to kind of arms dealers that
have got on the wrong side of russia
through to
democratically elected governments who
kind of aren't in line with what they'd
like
it's that diversity of victims i think
has created
this shared sense of concern
and a determination to prevent further
such activity taking place
so for me as someone kind of responding
to this i think
that's been most interesting for me
so you you kind of said at the beginning
about how you know the activities that
this unit is accused of doing
is just way outside how these kind of
people would operate
what does that make you think when you
realize that
i guess for me when you work on counter
terrorism certainly you know
within the service you might expect at
some point to deal with a horrific kind
of potential for
lethal acts on uk soil that is a reality
of counter-terrorism work
it was absolutely not what i expected
when i started working on
counter-intelligence
a lot of our work against hostile states
focuses on espionage
as you'd expect spies investigating
spies to
put it crudely but then acts like
salisbury happen in the gray zone so to
speak and it makes you
stop and realize how worlds apart we are
from the intelligence agencies of
hostile
states both in our professional purpose
and goals but also the tools that we're
given to achieve those goals so i think
for me looking at what a unit like 29155
does
i think it's worth remembering this that
they are not a rogue unit they are part
of
the gru which in turn is part of the
russian intelligence services which
is in turn part of the russian state
this isn't a rogue unit they are
acting as part of the russian state
i think it's when you combine those
things that for
us that's kind of been quite shocking to
see and
certainly for me as an individual and
they they always use equivalence don't
they so
they they sort of use equivalence and
like counter deny
counter accuse and it does it can create
suspicion that maybe mi6 carried out the
poisonings
could you kind of tackle that one do the
intelligence agencies
in the uk conduct the same kind of
malign activities
that we're seeing the gru conduct no
absolutely not the salisbury attack
triggered multiple challenges for mi5
the rest of the uk intelligence
community
and the police first they had to
investigate the poisonings
and build a case against the culprits
then they had to help
ministers devise a retaliation in
coordination with allies
which led to the expulsion of 153
russian intelligence officers from
across the world
including 23 from the uk
finally the security service as well as
mi6
and gchq said they had to rethink
their assumptions about the russia
threat
tom again we probably hadn't calculated
just how
determined and ruthless our adversary
might be to conduct this kind of attack
what does that tell you then about the
threat well i mean it says
a lot about our adversaries which is
that they are ruthless
determined well resourced they have as
far as
we can determine a very different
political risk appetite
and in some senses there continues to be
a vigorous debate across government
about this
this was intended potentially as a
message to the uk government
so this was less about carrying out an
attack
than it was about sending a message both
to the individual people in the gru with
whom
he would have worked and to the uk
government in general
it's a very blunt way of delivering that
message though tom listed four areas
where rules or ways of working have
changed
since the salisbury poisonings to better
counter the russian threat
i think the first is that the uk
government has given us
as a community more powers and there are
more powers to come
this includes legislation that came into
force in 2020
giving officials the power to stop
someone at the uk's borders
if there's a suspicion they might be
involved in any kind of hostile activity
on behalf of another state i think the
second thing is our
ability to join up with particularly
police partners
has improved and our understanding of
the wide range of people in the uk
who might be under threat not just from
the russian state actually
but from a range of other hostile state
actors
has improved we know more
about who those people are we've evolved
a much more detailed process
to help us manage the threat to those
people and
provide advice guidance and other
mitigations to the threat they might
face
um can can you say a bit more about
what's done to help protect individuals
we get into difficult territory there
because clearly those individuals are
each unique and the
threats that they face are unique and as
a result
the way in which we would approach those
is unique and
tailored to each individual but suffice
to say
it could be anything from security
advice to physical arrangements around
their property
and movements to police support and it's
done in lockstep with the police in each
region
of the country to make sure that uh
there are no gaps
between our understanding of the threat
and the police response
and and is that something that did
change because of salisbury uh yes
it's been more on a more structured
footing i would describe it
what does that mean there is now a kind
of formal
process i don't want to get into kind of
boring governance but there is
now a structured process which the
police and mi5 go through
which will help us understand both what
the nature of the threat is and what the
mitigation should be
it was not done on as structured away
before
he said the third change prompted by the
salisbury spy poisonings
is how the uk is working even more
closely with allies when responding to a
threat by a hostile state
we were astonished and gratified from
very very early on in the salisbury
investigation
to receive literally dozens of offers of
assistance
information support from our
international partners
the 153 expulsions is a really clear
demonstration of the international
resolve to push
back against this act and i would say
that that spirit of international
collaboration has continued
and intensified both bilaterally nation
to nation
and also through the security and other
fora
that we sit in so this is much more of
an international effort than it probably
was
probably felt before salisbury finally
tom says there's a lot more
collaboration between the uk's spy
agencies
as well as the police when dealing with
russia
it mirrors the collaboration that had
already been happening to combat
terrorism
when tom talks about mi6 he uses their
other acronym
sis the secret intelligence service
we have always been on a journey towards
further alignment further joint working
further joint teams the
counter-terrorism work we do is
very joined up but i think what it's
done is it's further accelerated the
join up
of the russia mission as we would
describe it to the point where we now
have
a single russia mission jointly governed
jointly led
jointly prioritized with joint teams in
many cases
co-located to ensure that the
intelligence inputs
and our ability to align what we're
doing against the greatest threats
is as efficient as it can be we can't
afford to have
gaps in our communications with each
other kate
described how this merging of resources
felt from her perspective
i mean i would say as someone working on
it i feel
as much kind of officer of the uk
intelligence community
as i do as an officer of mi5 i speak to
my counterparts in sis and gchq
every single day i talk to them as often
as i talk to people internally you know
it very much
feels we are one mission working to a
single set
of objectives against this target set
and as you'd expect when you pull your
resources when you pull your knowledge
you just have a much broader view and
we're also bringing together lots of
different talented individuals with
different areas of expertise
and it enables us to be as ambitious as
we can be as creative as we can be
and how we tackle this threat in that
sense it's kind of
been an exciting time to work in this
area to really see that join up
come again i think alongside that i
would say that
what has changed and i think this is
probably already in train before
salisbury
is an expectation by government that we
do more with what we
know so we have historically had an
amazing ability to collect
analyze understand intelligence about
russian activity in the uk
but the expectation on us from
government now
is that it's less about what we know and
more about
what we can do with what we know which
matters so my teams and the teams right
across the uk
community are thinking all the time
about the outcomes and the impacts
rather than the knowledge
that they can develop a desire to do
more with what they know
could even be why tom and kate have
agreed to this interview
speaking more about her work kate says
she thinks unit 29155's mission
is centered on eliminating russia's
enemies abroad and destabilizing the
west
effectively a deniable group of
individuals or at least
i assume their intention was to be
deniable
but to conduct what is pretty dirty work
on behalf of
on behalf of the russian state
and do you have any reason to believe
that the unit 29155
is still active maybe even here in the
uk
so i think what i'd say is any unit
whose remit
is as broad as we've discussed sabotage
subversion assassinations i think
they are a unit we will have to continue
to worry about
the pattern of activity we've seen over
the years would suggest that
but again they haven't been wildly
successful there's an awful lot that's
been published in the media about
the unit and about the units activities
whether those things will have an
impact on their ability to operate it's
it's still to be seen and sort of going
into
more detail about how they actually
operate can you
say like what you've learned about their
modus operandi
going um
so i guess a basic level you know this
is a special operations unit it's a
military unit
special forces type unit they will be
well-trained
military officers a lot has been said in
the media about the unit and its members
including naming individuals and
their backgrounds passport details
travel information
home addresses in some cases there's
arguably an unprecedented level of
information about the unit out in the
open
given it probably likes to think that it
acts clandestinely
what i can say is that investigating the
unit remains the priority for the uk
i imagine it remains a priority for
other international partners given the
global nature of this unit's activities
and
you'll understand that we don't want to
give too much away
about where we're at with our
understanding but certainly an
unprecedented amount of information is
out there
and can you kind of can you please put
it into context for people that don't
live in the
sort of spy world like how would you
feel if suddenly
in the same way as these guys have had
their
photographs and passports and their
histories plastered around the world's
media
like how would you feel if that happened
to you or one of your colleagues here
what is the effect of that i mean i'd be
feeling
very uncomfortable
even talking in this way is kind of
uncomfortable for someone in this world
so i imagine that they would be feeling
very uncomfortable when you join an
organization like
this and the intelligence services you
expect the organization to offer you a
level
of protection to enable you to do your
job professionally and to the best of
your ability i'd
be pretty concerned if i was undertaking
activity which
led me to be exposed in that way again i
think it comes back to the type of
activity that they're undertaking
when innocent people are getting killed
in the streets of europe that's not
something
people turn a blind eye to and will
cause this kind of scrutiny which
yeah for someone working clandestinely
is
going to feel uncomfortable when your
details are out there
[Music]
three years on from salisbury what does
the threat from russia look like
so there's a range of threats from the
russian state the first
obviously it was the threat from the
intelligence officers at the embassy
so we have pursued what the then prime
minister said in parliament after
salisbury where she said that we would
not allow the russian intelligence
services to rebuild their capabilities
in the uk
tom is talking about preventing moscow
from repairing the damage
done to its intelligence network in the
uk following the expulsion
of 23 russian spies including all of its
known
gru officers we know that the russians
are keen to rebuild their embassy
intelligence
officer carder we are very keen to
ensure that doesn't happen so a lot of
our work goes into that
but it has also expanded beyond that
into the
other nature of the threat and we've
been able to devote
more resources to looking at people who
might not be associated
with the embassy people who might be
here either
permanently or visitors under business
cover or
as journalists or academics or tourists
or others
who might want to come into the uk and i
think that's part of the reason why our
join up with other agencies like the
home office and the
police and borders is really important
because
those people aren't diplomats so we can
use different
investigative tools to deliver different
outcomes against those threats
i should also add i guess that we are
we're obviously looking more at
cyber alongside ncsc who are in the lead
with this
the ncsc stands for the national cyber
security center
which we covered in episode four and one
of the areas that mi5
is looking in particular well all of the
agencies are looking
at the way in which cyber intersects
with the real world
i think it's getting harder and harder
to see cyber as one thing in the
real world as another so we look in
particular at that
and increasingly we're also looking at
what you might describe as
the non-intelligence actors those actors
who are potentially
trying to influence or interfere in our
democratic way of life at the behest of
the russian state
but potentially with the knowledge of
the intelligence services as well
so that's clearly an increasing focus of
activity for us as well
i asked him whether the kremlin had been
able to reinsert any of its spies
so we we are working very hard to ensure
that they don't have you tried have you
have you been able to stop them
i would say that it would be a logical
assumption that having lost
23 intelligence officers the russian
government would want to try and
replace them in some way we work really
hard on preventing them from doing that
have we been entirely successful time
will tell
but as tom has suggested and as we've
heard throughout this series
hostile states don't need intelligence
officers
or even agents on the ground of a target
country
to launch an attack or meddle in its
politics
clearly spotting a foreign spy who's
say infiltrated a political party is a
job for mi5
but what about dealing with an
information campaign
on social media aimed at amplifying
divisions at election time
or dare i say it during the referendum
on brexit
especially when it's not clear if the
accounts
posting the content are backed by a
hostile state
or are simply genuine british voters or
politicians
making inflammatory claims
how to defend democracy was a key theme
in a parliamentary report on russia's
alleged activities in the uk
that was published in july twenty
a headline finding by the intelligence
and security committee
which oversees the uk's spy agencies
was that the government of then prime
minister theresa may
failed to conduct any proper assessment
into whether russia
had interfered in the brexit vote we
were concerned to note
that seeing the growing body of evidence
that russia did this kind of
interference in quite a sophisticated
fashion
uh that nothing had been done and indeed
the agencies themselves had been
not in any way encouraged indeed was a
bit of me which felt that they had been
discouraged
from reopening this issue and
retrospectively looking to see if there
was clear evidence of russian
interference
this was why we commented at our
surprise that we had been given
so little information on the subject
dominic grieve
a former conservative mp was chair of
the committee
when it compiled the report i asked what
made him think
british spies had been discouraged from
investigating potential russian
interference
clearly the intelligence agencies of the
united kingdom see their primary
function as being protecting us
against espionage subver and terrorism
and of course the moment they have to
carry out examination of what's going on
within an internal democratic process
that's a very delicate issue and as our
agencies have high ethical standards
it's an area that they're
probably not very keen on getting
involved in because it might give the
impression that they're being dragged
into making political judgments
but on the other hand it's worth bearing
in mind that one of the
uh require one of the remits
specifically set for mi5 for example
is the protection of our democratic
processes and i have to say that for the
future it seems to me as this
problem is developing globally that one
of the areas on which there's going to
have to be focus
is the extent to which our democratic
processes may be influenced or subverted
by external actors
it's also true though that the
traditional arms of government
tasked with protecting national security
like spy agencies and the military
can't deal with the full spectrum of
greyzone threats on their own
in 2017 mark sedwell now lord zedwell
when he was the uk's national security
adviser
devised something called the fusion
doctrine
the idea was essentially to bring
together all of our national
capabilities not just national security
capabilities
in pursuit of all of our national
objectives and for a country of our size
to do that in a coherent way could be
one of our key
advantages this doctrine recognizes that
different parts of government
such as health and education as well as
the private sector
are also needed to keep the uk safe
while lord sedwell appeared confident
his fusion mantra
is being fully embraced i'm not
convinced it's really achieving much
beyond a few more departments becoming
involved in national security meetings
and lots of talk about an all of
government approach
despite what the the idea of the fusion
doctrine and the need to be fused in
your response to these attacks
there does there seems to be a disparity
between the kind of acceptance
understanding or willingness to to adapt
amongst the different departments so
defense gets it
foreign office gets it home office gets
it to an extent but
does education get it does dcms get it
what do you think dcms stands for
the department for digital culture media
and sport
well i think they are getting it and so
if you look at the legislation that is
now
moving through in order to enable more
government intervention on national
security grounds
against particular to to to deal with
particular kinds of takeovers in
particular sectors and so on
that's that's come out of the business
department and the business department
is highly attuned now
to that the nature of that kind of uh
risk in a way they wouldn't have
been probably five years ago lord
sedwell is referring to the national
security and investment bill
which is designed to give the government
new powers
to ban foreign takeovers in sectors like
defence or energy
if they pose a threat to national
security
dcms are highly attuned to it you know
they're now they you know the digital is
now
a big part of probably a bigger part of
their brand than
uh it was before and they were
responsible for
the overall approach and indeed the
legislation uh in that is enabling us to
regulate telecommunications more
effectively and ensure that we have the
right mechanism in place to deal with
high-risk vendors
in in that area it's good to hear this
evidence of change
i just don't think it's anywhere near
profound or rapid enough
especially given the pervasive and
evolving nature of the threat
back with mi5 i asked tom whether he
thinks
the threat to the uk from russia is
increasing
i would say it is not i would say it's
evolving and diversifying
rather than getting worse i would also
say our understanding of it is probably
getting better so that means that there
is a risk
that it looks like it's getting worse
but i think it would be a mistake to
sort of
characterize this as a new cold war we
are pushing back as a government and a
population
a community against excess from a
foreign state
this is not a desire by the uk to engage
in
regime change or interfere in a foreign
government or foreign populations you
know democratic or
or not particularly democratic rights
this is about trying to correct and
bring back
into what you would describe as the
international norms
the behavior of foreign government that
is currently not behaving that way
so you're you're obviously very alive to
the threat and and there's clearly a lot
of work going on to identify and counter
it
but do you see it having any effect so
you get into the you get into the very
darkest spaces
around our intelligence collection and
insight there
and it's difficult for me to talk about
that i think we will be having insights
into that
and the policymakers in particular will
be receiving a flow of intelligence
about that some of that i may see some
of that i may not see
you know the paradox of this business
that i'm in
is that you can sit in a room full of
people and
never quite know what everybody knows
because the
compartmentalization process is such
that
some people may have had access to some
material and
some people may not so it gets quite
hard to know the entire position
you could describe it as maybe an
internal grey zone
but i would say that i think we have
optimism that by
continuing to continue the course of
action or the path we're on and ensuring
and encouraging our partners to do the
same that
that is the right thing to do i am
hopeful that that will
ultimately be fruitful whether it has
yet been fruitful in a way that
we need it to be is probably more open
for debate
there is not much doubt that the russian
state continues to conduct attacks
against the uk
including cyber attacks on a daily basis
but are we are we are we safer in the
wake of salisbury
in the wake of all that we know of it
people like you have
understood and learnt and with this
legislation that you've talked about
that's coming online are people in the
uk safer
i cannot say with certainty having
discussed with you the sort of size and
shape of that
novichok bottle and how easy it would be
to smuggle another one of those into the
uk
i cannot say for certain that we are
safe
we live in a liberal democracy in the
same way that our
counterterrorism colleagues would say we
can't prevent every attack
we can't prevent an incredibly
well-resourced
determined and ruthless adversary from
finding some kind of way of
getting something like novichok in i
suppose the questions we ask ourselves
are
around essentially intent and capability
do we stand a better chance of knowing
that something is coming
probably although i would say the pace
of technological
change means it's an absolute arms race
for us to keep up with the way in which
technology is evolving
encryption etc so how do we
how do we stay ahead of that to
understand if something is coming
that's a key element can i say with
certainty
that we would have a better chance of
spotting something after it happened in
the way
that we did with salisbury i feel very
confident and i am at times
frankly humbled at the amazing abilities
well police colleagues particularly to
forensically
unpick crimes such as the one that
happened in salisbury
it is a remarkable thing to actually be
close to a major investigation like that
so
are we are we closer to being able to
see those things and
identify the attackers and the way in
which something has been
carried out against us i would say yes
so then it comes down to intent
and i guess the question for us has to
be are we
in a position to persuade the adversary
whoever it is
russian state the decision makers at the
top of the russian government
whether the personal political economic
reputational costs
of carrying something out and getting
caught are worth it
i think success for us as a government
and a country looks like those people
concluding that the cost of doing it and
being caught and the international
response which it would produce
means that it's just not worth it
and i think that's when we as a country
and a community are
in a position to start moving those
decision makers back into the space of
saying
actually we should behave in a more
kind of responsible way as an
international partner
and rewarding them for doing so and
do you think maybe that the calculation
for them is changing when they look at
the uk because of the response they've
seen
well i would very much hope so
i think our ability to call out those
actions were they to take place has
increased
so they will have to be making a
different set
of calculations but i can't claim that i
really understand the set of moral or
legal or
operational reputational calculations
that the gru
senior leadership or the russian state
senior leadership are making
because it feels to me if you look at
the salisbury attack
that this was a wholly disproportionate
and
outrageous you know invasion against the
united kingdom
and we can't have anything but kind of
disgust for it
are they still interested in people in
the uk the reason we have a very
developed understanding of the people at
risk
and the mitigations that i've described
in place
is because we know that the russian
state continues to take an interest in
people here
who we deem to be at risk and that's
not a passive interest it's quite an
active interest
so we think that they are probably still
trying to collect information about
people
to what end it's not immediately
apparent
but we're not going to take any risks of
finding out that the intelligence that
they've been collecting
has been towards some kind of physical
attack we will continue to push back and
call that out where we see it i asked
the russian embassy in london
whether it wanted to respond to the
allegations about trying to rebuild its
team of intelligence officers
and about russia taking an interest in
certain individuals in the uk
i've yet to receive a response to those
questions
and are there attacks that have happened
that just haven't been made public
in what sense well we know of the
salisbury attack obviously and we know
about
cyber attacks against laboratories and
research facilities and we know about
the
pre-election hack and leak job but is
there stuff bubbling around below the
surface that doesn't peek through
the threat is manifesting itself
constantly both inside the uk
and outside and we are constantly
suppressing it where we can
wherever we can wherever we find it
it is that truism about intelligence
work
that our successes are very often secret
and our failures are very often public
so i would say that we have an amazing
collaborative community of like-minded
people who are
determined to protect the uk and they're
doing
a really good job at it in my opinion
but as we've heard throughout this
series
the nature of warfare is changing
spies and soldiers can't be the only
line of defense
not when it's people's minds freedoms
way of life that's under attack
we're neither in a state of peace nor
are we in a state of war
but we're sitting in this very dangerous
place
between the line between truth and lie
is a continuation of the line between
peace and war
so that the stakes here are extremely
high information warfare goes on all the
time
and i call it the 4d model which is
dismiss distort
distract and dismay weaponization of
information to kind of taking things and
then saying well
how do i use this in the most disruptive
or kind of coercive way
the whole aim is to create disturbance
to discredit us in this instance and
simply to cause
a problem to cause turmoil to cause
upset
looking for a cyber pearl harbor as
people call it
one massive event to change the course
of history
may actually be missing the point that
there's already
so many uh smaller events happening that
really should be stopped
cyber is not online cyber is use of the
online environment to change things in
the real world
we need to be able to compete with our
adversaries we need to be able to
contest
in cyberspace until the spark
there isn't a spark there is potentially
a very dangerous flash point
and it's a more dangerous flash point
today than it was two or three years ago
you've got a a world with far more
weaponry in it
and that means that a miscalculation
could be really rather horrific if it
occurs
in the gray zone the front line is
everywhere
no one is too unimportant to be a target
that's why everyone has a part to play
in
understanding the threat ignore these
warning signs
and life might just change without you
realizing
until it's too late you want to boil a
frog
you don't drop it into boiling water
because it'll jump straight out again
you put it in cold water and you slowly
bring the water up to boil
by the time the frog realizes it's
getting too hot
it's lost the energy to be able to jump
out we're being
boiled like a frog we can prevent that
if we don't then the answer is enjoy the
gathering storm
because bad news is coming
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and michael greenfield
and narrated by me debra haynes
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
you